rentrée toujours mais à présent du côté
de l'université de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines et pas de mauvaise
surprise pour les étudiants est la
nouvelle ufr des sciences de la santé a
bien ouvert ses portes ce matin pour le
traditionnel amphithéâtre de rentrer à
l'aménagement des locaux est livrée tout
juste avant les vacances s'est déroulée
sans accroc johanna soudry elodie moines
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines se développe sorti de terre
près du centre commercial sqy ouest
un nouveau bâtiment accueille désormais
les étudiants de l'ufr des sciences de
la santé
communément appelée fac de médecine les
jeunes ont découvert leurs locaux
flambant neufs
ce que vous savez grâce à un nouveau
bâtiment ouais il était quand c'est stan
est déjà rentrée n'ont jamais lâché la
première qu'est ce que vous en attendez
de ce bâtiment bail doit il doit être
bien
être moderne et moderne c'est toujours
mieux il ya moins de problèmes
techniques
c'est peut-être mieux pour apprendre
aussi moi je n'aime pas trop ce que
c'est bien sûr la plus nos repères c'est
pas nous
de mérode non non ce matin 856 étudiants
de première année ont réalisé leur
rentrée ce qui change c'est d'abord et
avant tout d'avoir un bâtiment moderne
se construit selon les normes hqe club
et surtout avec un équipement
informatique et numérique tout à fait
adaptée aux défis modernes de
l'enseignement avec des tableaux
interactifs
de quoi rassurer les premières années
qui devraient se partager le mans de 200
places en fait des remous du caire et
paramédical et à l'issue de cet
amphithéâtre de rentrer nous avons
rencontré la responsable administrative
de ce tout nouveau site pour une visite
guidée mais aussi le nouveau doyen en
fonction c'est l'autre nouveauté de
cette rentrée pour les étudiants en
médecine
c'est le jour de la rentrée ici j'ai
envie de dire à la fête de médecine de
50 ans ni vie mais je crois que je vais
me faire reprendre parce que c'était pas
le terme exact c'est à dire que
historiquement vous auriez raison mais
et même si la majorité des étudiants
seront des étudiants en médecine en fait
c'est plutôt limitée à la médecine parce
que c'est un fr des sciences de la santé
c'est à dire que dans la nouvelle
réforme des études si vous voulez de la
santé il y a non seulement les étudiants
en médecine mais il ya les étudiants en
pharmacie les étudiants dentaire et
aussi les sages-femmes olivier dubourg
vous êtes le nouveau doyen est ce que
c'est correct de dire ça c'est à dire
que le doyen en fonction c'est djillali
annane qui est élu jusqu'en 2015 en
janvier 2015 et qui est devenu
conseiller de marisol touraine et donc a
priori il ne peut plus exercer ses
fonctions il est empêché et dans le
règlement de de l'ufr
le visuel en premier si vous voulez
premier assesseur plus exactement a pour
fonction de le remplacer lorsqu'il y
avait un empêchement
justement quelles sont les
particularités de ce nouveau bâtiment
eh bien il est déjà à ce qu eux autres
qualité environnementale c'est un
bâtiment donc qui fait quatorze mille
mètres carrés qui est nous a été livré
le 29 juin donc en fait il ya très peu
de temps tous les étudiants de médecine
seront regroupées ici dans cet unique
bâtiment à présent non il n'est en faite
ça concerne les premières années
médecine qui suivent leur enseignement
ici lé l2 et l3 ensuite les autres les
autres enseignements se passe sur les
hôpitaux économie à présent le medef
vient de tenir son université d'été dans
les yvelines dans une demi heure le
président justement de l'antenne des
yvelines va me rejoindre pour dresser un
bilan de cette édition qui s'est achevée
le 31 août dernier
auparavant johanna soudry patrick
jacques de dixmude reviennent sur ces
trois jours de conférences de débats et
de rencontres organisées par
l'organisation patronale
c'est pourquoi nous vous demandons
monsieur le premier ministre d'entendre
cette vérité première
nous ne faisons pas semblant d'aller mal
pour obtenir dernière université d'été
pour laurence parisot présidente du
medef
comme chaque année le campus d' hec si
tu as joué en josas accueilli le grand
rassemblement des chefs d'entreprise
pendant trois jours avant la rentrée
mercredi 29 août le premier ministre
jean-marc ayrault s'est rendu sur place
pour le lancement
je m'étonne de cet étonnement à propos
de ma présence parmi vous
et pendant 35 ans j'ai rencontré des
chefs d'entreprises dont venir à
l'université d'été c'est une première
mais rencontrer des chefs d'entreprise
pour moi c'est une habitude parce que
c'est une évidence
on construit pas l'avenir du pays sans
se parler est d'abord parler avec les
chefs d'entreprise comme je parle aussi
avec les salariés comme je parle avec
tous les français donc pour moi c'est
évident je répondu à votre invitation
c'est une grande première ce nicolas
sarkozy ancien président de la
république avait participé à la
rencontre du medef en 2007 plus jamais
un premier ministre en fonction avait
fait le déplacement
nous étions quittés avant l'été sur une
mésentente lors de la grande conférence
sociale le travail avait bien sûr repris
depuis mai où semblait absolument
indispensable qu'il y ait un signe du
gouvernement à l'égard des entreprises
pourquoi parce que celle ci traverse une
période extraordinairement difficile
ceci nous concerne tous pas simplement
nous chefs d'entreprise pas simplement
nous cadres dirigeants mais tous les
français car la croissance passe par les
résultats des entreprises
l'intervention de jean marc ayrault a
été appuyé par une forte présence des
membres du gouvernement comme michel
sapin ministre du travail pierre
moscovici ministre de l'économie et des
finances ou encore arnaud montebourg
ministre du redressement productif
aucune annonce concrète de la part du
premier ministre mais un appel à la
négociation sur la sécurisation de
l'emploi
à quelques jours de la publication des
chiffres du chômage en forte hausse eux
jean marc ayrault est revenu sur le
projet des quatre cent mille contrats
aidés sans oublier les emplois d'avenir
quant aux emplois d'avenir dont le
projet était adopté ce matin par le
conseil des ministres il contribue aussi
à apporter une réponse à la fois rapide
et ambitieuse à cette question
ambitieuse car nous voulons créer cent
cinquante mille emplois d'avenir dès la
première année et avec ces emplois nous
visons d'abord les jeunes les plus
éloignés de l'emploi
ceux qui sont sans diplôme ou qui sont
peu qualifiés en priorité dans les
quartiers les plus populaires ou dans
les zones rurales en difficulté une
proposition loin de satisfaire la
présidente du medef qui regrette la fin
du dispositif zéro charges pour toute
embauche nouvelle dans une tpe et ce
serait certainement beaucoup plus
vertueux pour tout le monde de créer
d'assiter les emplois dans le secteur
privé plutôt que dans le secteur public
ou associatif notamment du côté du
secteur public il faut faire très
attention on a quand même un enjeu
d'équilibré des finances publiques qui
est un sacré défi
et puisque nous parlons politique cette
information officielle à présent henri
guaino est candidat à la présidence de
l'ump l'ancien à l'ancienne plume de
nicolas sarkozy se présente donc pour
décrocher la tête de l'ump il est
également député de la 3e
circonscription des yvelines
on passe aux sports à présent nous
allons parler des jeux paralympiques